[Music]
it has been nine years since the
original release of Jojo's Bizarre
adventure's All-Star Battle on the PS3
and it was exclusively on the PS3 but
now it is out everywhere on PC PS5 Xbox
you name it JoJo fans all around the
world Rejoice you can finally play as
your favorite characters so let's just
dive in and see what has changed
quotes on the screen there's All Star
Battle arcade versus online and practice
mode and we're going to run you through
some of the new features in additions to
the game the first thing you'll notice
is that there isn't a story or campaign
mode that has been replaced with the
All-Star mode and also they have read
the stamina mode of the first game which
is definitely a welcome change so you
are limited and can keep playing for as
much as you like there are eight panels
in total with one of them being a boss
panel involving actual fights that
happen in their respective timelines
that's aux that has to be unlocked by
completing a number of panels on the
side not all the battles are Canon so
you don't have to worry about spoilers
if you're new to the franchise but they
are definitely cross Arc battles such as
Dior from Phantom blood what's this deal
from Stardust Crusaders and the dialogue
between them is golden
[Music]
standard
and that goes for all the other fights
as well but we'll get into that in a bit
CP Evil part 4 Diamond is unbreakable
you'll need to win four battles before
playing the fight between jotaro Kujo
and yoshikage Hira but in page 2 of
battle tendency you only need to clear
two battles before unlocking the boss
panel between Joseph and cars all the
pages and panels save for the boss
fights are available to you from the
get-go also there are modifiers special
rules for the fights which helps vary
the flow so no two fights are the same
they also have secret missions that you
can pay 250 gold for to reveal but you
can also play around and see what works
you can unlock outfits uh and more by
completing them so it's worth a shot
being a completionist for newer players
there's the easy beat system now that
triggers all the combos by button
mashing the same button which makes it
super accessible
you can also buy support effects to help
you in your battles if you find yourself
being utterly
so there are a lot of options available
to help newer and even returning players
with their fights remember there's no
shame in asking for help and now the
arcade mode the arcade mode has
challenged battle and endless battle in
challenge mode you have 8 consecutive
fights lined up and if you region as
great with a couple of characters you'll
earn bonus gold depending on your
challenge difficulty next up endless
battle it pits you in fights with
opponents they got stronger with each
round your health carries over and
you'll gain more Health back depending
on the time you have remaining on top of
all of that there's also Harvest Time
reference to the stand of course and it
appears every once in a while so play
while it's on increases the goal from
your normal results a bonus multiplier
if you will so make sure to hit the
arcade once you see those yellow
Gremlins around the title next up the
shopping gallery basically you can view
and buy bonus content like voice actor
lines 3D models 2D models dildo JoJo
glossary and more and you have access to
them whenever you want provided you've
unlocked them in the customize section
you can edit the various character
actions poses lines and Screen effects
for their taunts and victories if you
unlock or buy character models you will
have more options to customize your
character you can also edit your player
card here with any tagline that you've
unlocked with the medals the previous
roster of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
All-Star Battle was it 40 but now there
are 50 characters in The remastered
Edition new characters include
Speedwagon Maria Pet Shop Joe Tower from
part 4 yukako Trish prosuto and pesky
giaccio FF and Diego also ikuro
hashizawa is back which newer JoJo fans
may not be familiar with and that's
because he exists outside the universe
but is another creation of hirohiko
araki and it's nice that he's back
because he was in the original roster so
fans of the predecessor don't worry your
favorite bio weapon is still there of
course all the characters are available
from the get-go so any aspiring or
current fighting Esports players can get
a feel for them before they take it to
the tournament you can totally play as
Paul Nero's best friend Iggy in his epic
battle with pet shop now
of course all these characters have
different styles that come on where you
can charge your HH altimeter vampirism
stand
ing there are also others like mounted
for diesel and Johnny
Olga Street for Speedwagon
watch it
later and of course bow arm phenomenon
for ikuru hashizawa a lot of the
original voice actors or CU and you're
one say in the case of Jordan Cujo who
is now voiced by Fire's eye instead of
Miyuki saloshiro have redone their voice
lines and they all sound so much more
comfortable in their roles after all
these years so mad respect for the voice
actors were coming back and re-recording
your lines you guys are awesome and the
fans love them
also the character models now closely
reflect the ones in the anime so that's
even more juicy Joe Jonas to bite into
it is a beautiful game with Rich visuals
amazing voice acting and tons of
abilities to learn and master if you are
a JoJo fan you need to get your hands on
a copy anyway if any of you out there
have any questions leave them in the
comment section down below and I'll do
my best to get to them and I'll catch
you soon take care foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]